go alive okay and we are alive hello and
welcome to round two but the stream team
and this is where we sit and talk to
content creators about what they're
doing what their journeys are and where
they are today and today we would like
to welcome our good friend dr. Bob here
from with UT games he is the third
person of the team and as you seen the
other two in the past two weeks and now
this is dr. Bobby is the the trifecta if
you will how you doing my friend I'm
doing good you know I slept till on noon
today even though it's supposed to be
working from home my boss is on my
podcast I don't know I supposed to be
working
telling you that you know telling people
you're a doctor oh my god okay all right
look that was like week two of
voicemails in our podcast and I have no
say in these things we tell our
community just call it call it as long
as I start to us and you're not gonna
get us kicked off at which we'll play it
but nine times out of ten it's just
people making fun of me I I think that
it's very mean I did I did I will say
I've done a couple phone calls you guys
yes you have the first one you were
screaming at us on the highway yes the
first highway the second one I was not
so screaming but I was but you know I
tried I try to not bust you guys chops
too much and I defended you and your
animal crossing like I came to your
defense with animal crossing because you
and me are the same boat we don't we're
not huge fans of Animal Crossing I just
don't get it I don't understand the
appeal that the two other people on this
show Ellen MJ they both love Animal
Crossing but we'll get into that because
I know what's gonna come up somehow
great it always does
so well thank you very much for coming
greatly appreciate you being able to
take your time to come to the show of
course thanks for stop talking about
and that was miss l-boogie Oh 208 how
are you I'm good I'm actually really
good like I have to say you know like I
said last week those uh sleep pill
thingies are the best yeah changing your
life yeah I'm happier at work and stuff
like man happy at work
that's right agree when I get home I
don't want anywhere where cuz home I'll
work a song but you get to you know just
wear pajamas to work everyday I don't do
that because I feel like that's an easy
way to get depressed oh I do that every
day I don't care you mean you're not
like at home all the time
well no no i-i've been working from home
to three days a week but that's still
not been in the house since early March
oh yeah I will tell you this
I don't know if anyone else has this
problem they go food shopping and ended
up going to whatever the local food
store is and I spend a hundred dollars
on food even though you were there two
days prior I went to the food store
three times this week I don't know why
the first time I went for normal reasons
the other time because my mom needed
something and the third time was because
my mom forgot something each time I
spent $200 at the food store I don't
know why but it happened I mean the only
thing I've spent $100 on consume ibly is
on alcohol and that's it I will say I've
spent over a hundred dollars twice on
meals but that was because was
Cheesecake Factory
all right that's that's acceptable
that's like that's enough food for like
a week though wait are you guys saying
that you don't even when you go to like
a restaurant to eat you won't spin over
a hundred or oh well Oh sushi easy okay
I'm sorry
something came across my screen and I
read it and I didn't hear that last part
so sorry we will do we will do that we
will do that so good well I'm happy you
were able to join us today thank you
very much for coming
MJ what's going on bhai what's poppin
what's poppin how is your life going
with no more school for the semester
semester is over it's doing good doing
good just playing games now I'm not
working until everything's clear what
are you out for this summer yeah I'm on
summer break now how long is that for
you guys until August unless they do the
online school for next semester too I
always hated that felt like the summer
school stuff the options were like
crappy you know yeah that's even worse
right now do you guys feel like you
learn more or less when you do online
schooling less and retain less for sure
I can't do all my schooling it just
doesn't work for me I can do it I'm like
the bomb at it we'll get it yes I'm
definitely getting an A in any five-week
course like but I'm not gonna retain it
so I have to be sitting in front of her
professor I have to sit there and talk
to them
tip I grad school in an online course
but I also said I also spent a year
doing online courses but that a year
inside of a hospital doing clinical
rotations and class wise it was just me
teaching myself the whole time
critically that's class yeah exactly
clinically it's completely different cuz
I was inside of a hospital but like
teaching classes or like learning from
classes I'm not peeing I look man you're
an okay guy you're an okay teacher I'm
not gonna listen to you for two and a
half hours straight
he's just not that interesting to me
buddy I think I might have told this
story on the show but we had a assembly
language professor that smelled so bad
she smelled so bad like literally one of
her classes actually went to the Dean
and said you have to either get rid of
this teacher or make sure she showers
because she smells so bad it was that
bad but yeah
and but I digress so um MJ what do you
what's your weekend how you were you
playing anything fun this weekend um I
just beat Final Fantasy 7 remake and I
started persona 5 rail edition a little
bit of war zone and I picked up predator
hunting grounds that's okay
do you like beer no it's okay it's fun
with friends I mean if you have a group
of friends to play with and I mean yeah
you can if you don't need me waiting a
while but involved yeah it's it's the a
plate of all I don't really like it it's
I'm not evolved yeah is it better or
worse issues um I don't know I didn't
play a whole lot of evolved and that's
the thing yeah it's definitely it's
quality it's pretty good I liked evolved
but like it like you'd like elbow say
there was definitely bugs yeah I think
that um aren't the server's down for
evolved
her Ambrose I believe yeah I believe
they took him down yeah yeah they're
went free to play and went free to play
for a little bit yeah because I it
crashed and burned so hard after release
and then I think it was like three years
after a released they went free-to-play
and then they shut the server's down
yeah you know it's so much potential to
its dead by daylight it came before dead
by daylight shoot and kill the monster
that game came out and what like 2012
Friday the 13th was fun as hell I think
I think there was a license dispute
after release for Friday the 13th no for
Friday the 13th
ok and they they I guess they can no
longer update the game so who knows how
long those servers will go right that's
crazy it was it was a fun game did you
ever fight I never played for a little
bit I know I know one of the devs
because you used to be on the division
team no like you know Matt catcher Matt
and that's the mats awesome
well like he became one of the
community matters for them and like I
saw him playing the game show everybody
the game it was a good game his quality
was good it's good what about you Elle
what did you end up playing this weekend
did you have a good fun-filled weekend
played a ton of Call of Duty like I
stayed up super late on Friday and then
I played John Orr's on
yeah war zone I don't know like as
you're on the Box on the Xbox I'm not
playing on the PC but yeah I am I see is
inundated with cheaters that's why yeah
but you know they're making us play with
them and I hate it yeah that's true
because you see like people doing like
you know that you know that there's
cheaters you know like it's bad because
it's easier to get into the code the
coding for it all right
mm-hmm and they make you play with them
that's what the problem is is that you
can't turn it off to not play with them
they should allow that seven they should
have just let it be separate they do in
multiplayer but not for war zone for war
zone you have to play with them I think
do you think they're trying to do that
because like fortnight it keeps the
lobby time I think it keeps the lobby
sorry yeah JB thanks how you doing man
what's going on yes Bob's here to talk
about himself it's gonna be fine Chris I
see Chris is in the chat - happy
birthday JB Oh way to go and Christopher
Hart what's going on man
yes we know they're full of factors so
and everybody knows me now though Pete I
didn't even do my introduction I just
went with it
all's good things are better had a
service technician to my house for my
internet again yeah man yeah every week
you're having so so long story short the
technician came out Saturday morning he
told me that I told him I was like
there's nothing you could do
everything's been changed in the house
everything's changed out here there's
something wrong with the line I think
there's something wrong with one of the
nodes I think someone's stealing your
internet or clogging the pipe so I was
like you got to figure out what's going
on these are the tie actually gave him
times
for Monday to Friday I was like these
are the times they're having problems
you got to check it so he's like alright
well I'll see if I can have somebody
pull the logs
he's like the guys on shift he's like
we'll see what we could do all escalated
to a tier two technician my parents are
coming home from my brother and
sister-in-laws they happened to see a
guy on the pole I went to the guy in the
pole and I was like dude what's going on
this is what's happening what's
happening going on do you see anything
and he goes yeah we're seeing actual
problems on the nock we actually see
issues so we have to trace it so they're
actually going from node to node in our
area for nodes but they're all like in
people's like homes by their homes so
they have to like get permission to get
on their house to go on it's a long
annoying story but they're going on some
people's like houses they check the
nodes and they're following the noise on
the line and once they centralized the
person's house where the sound is coming
from the filter on it and kill their
internet connection so they'll have no
internet but everybody else will be
working fine so there's still one anyway
internet anyway well that's I think if
that's what it is but I don't know these
people so hopefully they can under
fixing it fingers crossed because this
has been taking too long but at least
now people know which is good so that's
that played a bunch of Assassin's Creed
origins this weekend trying to get back
in that was that how's that going
it is good it's it's weird because I
haven't played Assassin's Creed in so
long but it's been good isn't it
different than the other ones the combat
system has no change that's when they
changed a combat system and I'm still a
little angsty and annoyed by gonna play
Odyssey I'm gonna try to beat origins
Odyssey before Valhalla comes out are
you gonna get the DLC I need to get the
DLC because I don't want to do hidden
blade that's it am I the only one am I
the only one who is completely
underwhelmed by Assassin's Creed
Valhalla yes you are alright I will say
this I'm a huge fan of the Assassin's
Creed series I've played every single
one of them and that by the way that was
a discussion you guys were having on a
show on your show last week yeah Bob and
I was getting so annoyed
because I was like you're all wrong
you're all talk about your bro
but I didn't call the hands I'm so so
that's that's just another franchise I
don't get I don't get it I don't
understand the appeal if Assassin's
Creed Valhalla looks that trailer wah
looked incredible show me some gameplay
show me some in-game footage and show me
why it's gonna be at the same level as
God of War and if it's not at the same
level of God of War I don't care what I
saw so many memes online Daryl and I
just greet Valhalla or is it just for a
hundred Vikings yeah that too because
that's that's what a lot of people were
saying because they were like they
literally just took the the Vikings
people and put them into that but I
agree with you like first of all I don't
like the new combat system I don't like
it I don't like having to trigger it to
attack and to do this in that highlights
having one button to attack one button
to assassinate stealth in people I like
the original combat system way better
than the new one I'm just trying to
force my way through so I can see the
story and so I could see the game and
doctors why I'm trying to push my way
through it just watch them cool be
online then like I visit that much of it
if it's that much of a pool like I have
to push myself then watch the movie I
dropped it front I dropped it to normal
I had it on hard so I dropped on to
normal essence great games are hard for
me I'm not good at those I always
struggle really yeah I don't know I'm
not gonna stealth games know what oh man
I literally took an hour today taking it
down like just like one fort just
walking around killing people so so much
I love it it's so good if I just run
around SAS any people and I came up yeah
but then there's 632 other forts that
you need to take down I know that is
another thing I don't know much that's
the screed there's too much there's too
much but like that's the thing I'm just
gonna blitzkrieg through the main part
of the story keep my level like G on to
what I need and that's it that's all you
have to do a lot of side missions in
that game before you complete the main
story I forget I'm pretty sure origins
yes
yeah I'm pretty sure origins came out
and it was like there was a level cap to
actual game progression where you needed
to go grind to get that love yeah that's
that's that's what I'm at but the other
one
what is it Odyssey is not you can say
that you want your level to be you know
equal to or too hot like the people
you're fighting has two levels higher
like you can do that and it does work
out that's honestly though that I want
to see and I definitely want to do the
first blade which is the first hidden
blade added it's good so cool
we have a doing some of that stuff and
you know Wow get the end of that what
and a while me and um what's his name he
added me on snapchat from the mostly
something yeah he says that he got a
gaming PC today and he said that he's
building it parts are on the way let's
play Wow with you go ahead man to horde
go horde go on : soldier and I'll hook
you guys up okay
it's good its quality it's really good
game cuz I I tried getting back in the
or I've tried getting into it like a
couples or I think it was like a year or
two ago and I just didn't have anybody
to play with and I'm just like no yeah
well people is it like destiny cuz it's
like destined I mean I don't like it'll
be it's it's different it's different
than us tonight it's a different type of
grinding
yes but we've been sitting here rambling
for what we've been doing for you know
in the past past weekend but what we're
all here for dr. Bob we want to know two
things from you one what did you do this
weekend what games you been playing and
also tell us about your life as a
content creator which do you prefer I
would say to what you're doing this
weekend first what games you're playing
and then if you don't mind going into
your your content creation yeah I mean
so this weekend I so I work my day job
is I work in a hospital I'm a physicist
so the majority of the time
currently right now I'm working from
home but I have to work on site like two
days a week at this point so over the
weekend I had to go into the hospital I
were good yeah
over the weekend I had to go to the
hospital and like it was only for a
couple of hours but that was about it
and then I didn't do anything else but I
did play a lot of video games I played a
good amount of Valor entrants came out
so I've been doing a little valent
ranked grinds even though I can only
really play it if I have a squad of
people on that's one of the it's like
Counter Strike for me I can't play solo
queue unless I'm playing on like a third
party like face it or you see a mm-hmm
yeah whenever my team's on we're playing
valent at this point if nobody's on I'm
grinding Final Fantasy 8 HD remaster
everybody's all up in arms right now
about the Final Fantasy 7 where you make
let me tell you something ok you want to
play a real Final Fantasy game you play
Final Fantasy 8 HD remaster it's like 16
dollars and you get to relive the
primetime PlayStation 1 turn-based JRPG
combat that everybody knows and loves
question how many missed all of the ones
before PlayStation 1 I had never played
so it was like 7 8 9 10 10 - I played
the 11 MMO for a little bit 12 13 was
terrible but I played for a couple of
hours I never played the sequels - that
I played deny or say ten - yeah 10 - and
50 I played a couple hours of 15 but I
don't I'm not a huge I'm a big
turn-based RPG fanatic so all of the
ones before 12 implemented
YOUnique gambit system that was it was
good enough on its own but I liked the
turn-based nature of the earlier games
yeah see I'm kind of like you I'd like
to turn based combat for the fantastic
games I've played most of them also I
actually believe it or not Final Fantasy
15 was the first one I never played and
I picked up 13 I hate it I never picked
a date I never played a bit about 12 I
played it for a little bit never
finished it I was just like this is
Carla but I've I was huge in 14 which is
the MMO huge on 11 which is the mmm um
10 is still my favorite yeah every day
at the end of every single every time
you see it when you see spoilers when
you see the water I'm not going I was
crying
first time I beat it the the CD crashed
in my my playstation 2 I had to reply it
to see the ending but the Final Fantasy
games the term based systems I feel like
are so good
now the action based system because I
feel like the next generation coming up
the MJ generation I should say
appreciates the the speed of combat
vastly more than the turn-based
situations to me to me turn-based
essentially create it's like it becomes
an RTS at that point like or maybe not
real-time and eight it's almost real
time because the whoever you're fighting
has you don't see their action bar but
they essentially have a blind action bar
like you do but um it becomes like it's
a strategy game at that point you're
fighting something you have to figure
out what its weakness is is if it's
vulnerable to this if it just absorbs
fire damage and you can't use fire
damage stuff like that so it's I don't
know I prefer that so much more than
like there's too many action games out
right now there's not enough turn-based
games which is why I kind of want to try
out persona at some points but I I'm
only I play I think I put in like 20
hours into Final Fantasy 8 this weekend
I played a lot and it was mostly just
grinding I was just level grinding and
that's the one with squall correct yeah
squall Leonhart yeah with the thing with
the whole thing with the unique thing
about that was the the money cuz like
yeah you ended up like ranking up a
certain class so if you were playing for
a certain amount of time you got money
and that was a really cool way that they
ended up doing you know the whole Final
Fantasy yeah until you start grinding
and then you need to use potions and you
have to go buy more but if you didn't
explore enough you weren't getting paid
so it's a baby yeah you have to like
rank up with tests or something for
remember yeah it's like the more
exploration you do your seed level
increases and then you get paid you get
paid X amount or if you're just playing
or if you're just fighting for long
enough you your seed level increases too
right right exactly there's no
traditional way of getting Gil yeah I've
got it
like I love I love Final Fantasy 8 it's
so I want to play it right now I want to
pull it up on my other monitor
it's very that's why I like I'm always
sitting back away from my computer
because I'm always don't wanna like III
need to multitask in some way that's why
that's what the chats goin so no easy
what's going on man mostly Martinez how
you doing bud I see you over here so
it's good it's good so is that is that
how your weekend ended up finishing up
yeah I mean I mostly just played the I
worked for a couple hours this weekend
and then I played didn't see the missus
now unfortunately not this weekend it's
uh you know because I have to be inside
of the hospital like around all the
nonsense that's going on right now it's
more of a all right I'll see you in like
2 to 2 2 to 3 weeks maybe maybe we'll
see so it's a big pain in the ass right
now but it's it's doable it's manageable
we're probably just gonna hang out
tomorrow anyway cuz like rolling this
yeah nobody cares at this point
yeah like let's see what happens it's
like everyone in California that was
protesting the beaches because they're
all sitting on the beaches Oh God
there's people protesting right now in
the mess Boston state house outside
give us our freedom dude you're free for
you to go home go home not in fact the
rest of the world yeah
go be free at your house yes fantastic
that's when I shake my head so so it's
all about you what you know give us a
little little overview about you and the
crew and your gaming career and well I
should say your you know your content
creator career because next week we're
gonna get the rest you know the rest of
the crew um we're gonna have all through
you here and I really want to dive into
you know the weekly gaming crew as a
whole and the site and all that other
stuff so yeah I mean so we launched
everything that we launched our website
wicked good gaming calm it's 2016 so
four years ago at this point I think
we're I think we just passed our four
year anniversary
well I have we completely missed it I
think but um yeah it's we launched a
passion project four years ago it
started out Dom and I where we'd play
D&D every Monday night we'd all get
together and we're like we want to do is
like let's do a podcast or something
like we get to the we get to the D&D
table or roll dice we'll get drunk and
then we'll talk about video games while
we're not playing Dutch it's dragons
like it adjourns so we're like why don't
we just do a podcast you know we have no
expectations of anything in the future
but mmm we it ended up getting narrowed
down to like me and Dom were the only
two who realistically wanted to do
anything with it and Dom was working
with Chris at the time so he was like
hey Chris would you be interested in
being involved in this and he said yes
he never decided he didn't want to tell
us ahead of time like hey once we get
the podcast going I might not be there
for a hundred or so episodes but you
know yeah we'll say sometimes that
happens yes it was like at the same time
that me and Dom were discussing at Dom
and Chris were discussing it do you guys
still do DMV so Dom is I took a step
back from D&D for a little bit I've been
trying to focus more on like actual like
getting content out like I because I'm
working I end up working like 50 hours a
week so
I leave it's tough to come straight from
work go straight to play D&D for four
hours when in that four hours like I
could be playing a game I want to talk
about or playing or streaming or
something like that so it's I'm trying
to allocate more of my time to
productive things even though I greatly
enjoy playing D&D it's it's a form it's
a secondary form of escapism like video
game like video games are yeah yeah I
actually I missed in D&D with my crew
because of this whole coronavirus stuff
I ended up having to talk to the crew
and we ended up deciding to like take a
little bit of time off for our TNT
campaign which kind of stinks because we
all miss it but I know a couple of
people on discord or actually doing D&D
groups but they're doing them like law
format like during discord they say okay
this is what's happening X Y & Z what do
you want to do and then they'll take the
next person and then the bit ago what do
you want to do and take the next person
so what ends up happening it sly Q don't
have to have a set time frame so you can
be doing D&D for like a week but like do
like three minutes here or five minutes
here or three minutes here or five
minutes there and then what ends up
happening is like you know you get a
campaign completed over time but you're
not committed to sitting down for four
hours
my only concern what that would be is
like at some point depending on how many
people are playing at some point
someone's gonna get disinterested by it
and they're not gonna pay attention to
it and it's gonna get dragged out for
longer than it has to people are gonna
forget what's actually happening even
though there's a text log above but I
seen it before I've definitely seen her
before
yeah sorry I digress go back to talking
with the Italian yes I look I'm right
there with you yeah sir I mean we
launched everything four years ago we
started we figured we want to do a
podcast but we should try to create a
following beforehand like we should get
a community going beforehand then we
launched a podcast and we'll see what
happens from there so we we
- wicked gaming in 2016 we wanted to
just be three people you're sitting at a
bar with talking about video games yeah
like we're just we don't we don't care
about everything else that's going on in
industry right now we enjoy playing
video games and we enjoy discussing
video games and we also like giving our
personal opinions on them if I don't
like a video game I'm gonna tell you
Animal Crossing new horizons Assassin's
Creed franchise was trash but like
that's the thing and we all have our own
unique like tastes in gaming you know
like Chris is a big first-person shooter
and the only other game he hasn't played
outside of first-person shooting his
bully which you know because you've
listened to the clutch that's before
last week yeah of course is and like Dom
has a wider array of like RPG games or
like specific adventure games that I
never played and then I played a gambit
of things like I I've gone through first
where I play plenty of first-person
shooters I go back through old RPGs like
I'm not much into new RPGs and stuff
like that or most action-adventure games
but there are franchises that like I
will play until I die like Final Fantasy
is a franchise if they ever circle back
around to turn-based that's a franchise
up late so I'd die God of War franchise
up wait till I die
stuff like that branch and quake oh yes
yes hoping they're gonna put me in my
grave with my PlayStation 2 and my
Ratchet and Clank well I'm trying to not
locked Oh pumpkin Jack and Jack
Oh pumpkin Jack I cannot wait if that
game gets delayed till next year would
be really upset you don't you got to do
I'm telling you right now just email the
devs cuz you know and just be like hey I
need an early release copy because I
just can't wait anymore
they said they told me they were they
were gonna send me whatever the earliest
release builder days yeah or pre-release
bill
yeah I it's like God Streets of Rage
like I couldn't wait for Streets of Rage
to come out like I could not wait for
Streets of Rage like I played it as much
as I could I tried to wait to play it
with my brother over the weekend and
guess what it didn't happen I just
played it like Friday night I was down
for the night I didn't stuff it's uh
this is gonna be one of those games that
could define in my opinion to find that
type of action platforming that we
haven't seen since a Ratchet and Clank
or a jak and dexter game like medieval
tried to do it but it was just a remake
and they didn't change it enough so i
don't know i think
pumpkin jack if you guys need a good
action platformer pumpkins about this
year what's it about yeah
you play as like a scarecrow it plays
similar to a Ratchet and Clank game
we're like you progress through levels
you get different weaponry you platform
around the map you fight enemies stuff
like that you find bosses in the end I
believe it's coming out to PC Xbox and
Playstation multiplied yeah
it's God I played it I cat I played it
at PAX and it was absolutely incredible
there's my game of packs but like we've
discussed him we discussed wood we
recorded the podcast yeah look
everybody's welcome
I know we people on all the time I just
laugh every time I was just like dude
and I just saw Tom's face like who asked
us we got we got hammered with the crew
what was it last year but they never for
some reason we were all in the VIP list
nobody came upstairs with us so well
first the first to start start by
explaining the predator party Wow what's
one last year this year so well you
start by doing last year's and then this
year's if it makes you feel feel better
chronologically
all right well I mean last year we so we
were out we're on we've been on the VIP
list for four years I think at this
point and last year we got in early for
the media coverage like the media thing
they want to show you all their new cool
tech that it costs fourteen thousand
dollars to put a gigantic gyro metric
gaming racing seat I'm sorry like it's
it's cool I don't have a separate room
in my house to put it unfortunately but
um yeah but they're showing you all
their like new PC stuff on their laptops
and whatnot which of course are much
more reasonable and then out I think it
was Dom DOM and I were checking out some
of their merch after we just grabbed
beers
Chris was m.i.a somewhere Chris was
being a Mike Chris was being Chris yeah
Chris is mi a similar if we don't know
what happened and then I'm walking over
to DOM and Donna's talking to I think it
was just King at the time yeah I camera
I look we were here I don't remember
yeah do what you want to wait for these
stories and we can just talk about it
next week with the whole yes all drunk
we're all drunk so so so a little
synopsis last year you guys met the crew
yeah it was a blast yeah this year
you met more of the crew he meant me and
a bunch of other guys yeah we had a
blast again yep and both times the last
year and this year we were having out of
her minds yeah and we introduced you
guys to what the VIP actually meant
which was go upstairs really thanks
phrase that was that's true I was there
last year so I cannot be you know thrown
in with that put that ball but the other
guys were yeah so they paid for drinks
and they pay for drinks praise learned
no longer will they have to do that and
I will tell you this l-boogie MJ you
guys better come next year if it's still
hacks and we're gonna get you guys out
and partying and the other thing was
that they said that Paxton is trying to
start reopening it in September
it's said that they're gonna try to have
the other ones open this year which I
don't know how they're gonna do unless
something changes I got screwed last
time at the Perimeter party because I
didn't get to sign up for the VIP thing
in time when the public line was like
super super long and I'm like nope I'm
not waiting so are you is there a 21 or
older for that or now for predator party
no no I think it's 18 plus but then you
need to get why wait are you not 21 I
have my ways
all right well look I've been there too
trust me but out dr. Evil's that [ __ ]
look man I had a fake ID like 15 I
looked like this at 15 it wasn't it
wasn't a big deal for me but um yeah I
think it's 18 plus but then you get like
stamped that you're not 21 yeah but
that's the other thing like if you roll
in VIP with us I think that they're
gonna still let you come in and you'd be
able to hang it out with us yeah
actually I can probably just sign up to
yeah yeah it's all set of emails
beforehand well we ever aways and I
would like I would like I said I would
love for you guys to come next year and
I would love for Elle to come next year
because I think she will have a blast
and even if she wants to come kid lists
and she just wanted to run around you're
muted I got you I got you I was gonna
say that that's hard to e3 but yeah Oh
see I'm trying I'm trying to convince my
wife to come on Sunday just to get
that's a good day because sunday is
quiet it's open as she doesn't like
crowds and by that time I like know my
way around that place because like the
first day you really go down there and
it's like you need to like get your
feelers out and figure out what's going
on and then five days three you're like
I know where everything is and by day
four you're just either a spent or B
you're just like okay
you can just law the
around so that's that's my plan for next
year
I can never do Sunday as much as I would
like to because it's so empty I'm just
completely toast by like a midday
Saturday where I can't do anything and
on top of that like I'll show like we
show up hungover on Saturday every
single day every single year yeah we
have no self-control
you know you learned that this year you
saw it firsthand do you remember what
happened with me no I was hammered I was
hammered no I don't remember any I left
at the perimeter party and no one
realized it except for and I walked over
everyone I said goodbye to them I'm like
I gotta go I'm too drunk to be here
right now I have to make sure I get home
and I got back to my hotel room
apparently I had a 30-minute
conversation about with my wife and then
she ended up telling me the next day
when I spoke to her she's like I only
understood every third word like that
look at happen I was like I got into my
uber and the guy the driver said Peter
and I said hey yes
and then the next thing I know the guy
goes what are you here for I'm like
we're here for the convention he's like
oh great he goes we're here your hotel
is here I was like okay cool I don't
know if I blacked out or passed out in
the car this is what happens when you
drink with us
guys that's that's just how it goes it's
what happens when you drink with us
welcome to Boston our hometown please
enjoy our beverages with us and then
forget everything that happened that day
yes also I can't eat I can't eat half
the food that they had there but that's
another story from now on I will
remember I will drink that mal yes I
look like Andy Samberg because my hair
is out of control right now and I
promised my wife for her birthday I will
let her cut my hair which I will be
streaming because it will be funny my
dad ended up getting a haircut this
weekend and almost but from my mom and
he almost got his eyebrow cut off with a
pair of scissors that [ __ ] was hilarious
I'm just saying the funniest thing I've
ever seen was my dad going like this
while my mom's going like this with a
pair of scissors I don't recommend it
hard-ass I'll let this grill out until I
shops up and back that's I was hoping
though by now but clearly they won't be
no way so see you guys with the with wit
gaming and everything you guys ended up
building your your website in your
community and now you you end up
streaming right a bunch of csgo I notice
and when we were at the predator this is
where I was going with a predator party
by the way they were on the big screens
they had csgo and throughout the whole
entire time we're sitting there going
these guys are terrible what's wrong
with these people
pros vs. joes yeah it was just like it
was it was hilarious
so by the way just let's say hey what's
up King in the chat and yes we have your
your with ug gaming
doppelganger Bob on the show you both of
you knees hurting and everything
yeah it's bad actually yeah I mean when
the so they had team Envy professional
counter-strike team playing they're a
North American team they just readjusted
their roster so they're they're like
considered a tier 2 team but they've
been playing well online recently and I
was so drunk that I was talking with
King and I was like look if I get on
that stage I will embarrass the pros
that's how good I know I am at this game
and that's how confidently drunk I am
right now to go make an embarrassment
out of myself potentially then I thought
he was just shooting hot air and I was
like I don't I did not know your skills
at that time I was just like he's just
smack talking and then I actually saw a
couple of his games he was playing he
said he's actually not that bad so you
know I'm like you're very good I am I'm
like slightly I would say I am slightly
above average overall at that
counter-strike but if I if I have an
okay team around me and I pick up an OP
and I primary off for our team then I
can make things happen then I can play
very well and I have a whole montage
video on our YouTube
and 90% of those kills are me using it
up yeah I looked at it was it's actually
it's very impressive it's very
impressive thank you I appreciate do you
do you see our chat by the way Bob
ah no King King is like four one three
six one six yeah he's doing all of his
ranting for you I mean look I agree with
them okay
there are just too many similarities
that he and I share to not be
counterparts from different universes so
assault on Bob if you will yeah that's
when he ends up deciding what things are
happening ahead of time kind of like a
what was it like um from big is that
where that came from
yeah or it's like Zoltar but Zoltan you
know so so he he knows the future he can
figure things out but what you would
never expect is that things that King
happens the king is the same things that
happened to Bob and when we're PAX East
King is just like oh my knee hurts and
Bob's life I busted my knee to yesterday
almost there like polar opposites it was
very very funny we yeah we definitely
have far too much in common to not share
some like ancestral bloodline for like a
hundred generations back yes or we're
just legitimate mirror versions of each
other from different universes it's
possible like look at look at the world
we live in right now okay
UFO information was just released come
on there it's a possibility different
was it called multiverses yeah exactly
we got a question go for it which system
are you gonna get next the ps5 for the
new xbox so
I genuinely don't care about the next
generation of consoles I'm primarily a
PC gamer yeah but I have every console
from this generation and there are pros
and cons to each one of them the switch
has the most unique set of IPs
but it's for little baby children you
don't say it like children should be
playing the switch but I own one and I
never play it Xbox has probably the most
accessible value to it with game pass we
pay ten dollars like five dollars a
month you have access to a hundred
something games that's intrinsically the
value on that just continues to go up
because they put new releases on it all
the time
playstation however has the best unique
IPS with blood-borne spider-man God of
War horizon zero dawn all of those
unique IPS that they have for themselves
separate themselves in my opinion so
currently the best system that I own
outside of playing PC because if I have
the option to play anything on PC I'll
do that first just because it's gonna
run better and it's way easier to stream
but yeah PlayStation currently this
generation is my it would be my go-to
for next gen it all depends on what the
exclusives are like if you're gonna tell
me that the next god of war is only
gonna be on PlayStation 5 I'm gonna get
a PlayStation 5 did you tell me that
right now I'll give you the money now
for both it's at that's it's that kind
of try for me spider-man 2 places your
five exclusive all right here you go
take my money that's all it that's all
it takes
halos never halos never coming out halo
infinite is never going to release okay
thank it's they talked about it and
that's it the game doesn't exist I
thought they said it was already ready
I don't believe show me gameplay footage
I need my footage if I don't get
gameplay footage I don't believe you I I
think that Hillary is gonna be coming
out I don't know the progress of when
it's coming out or what I I have a
feeling it's command for next gen it's
not coming up for this gen when it's
coming out I don't know king is saying
June 15th for halo he's saying halo June
15
yeah June 15th 2026 Lu if you say
something because you're meeting it
again alright but it's it's gonna be
launching with the console yeah he says
gameplay will be shown on June 15th yeah
you think they're good they're keeping
it silent until that date what's June
15th I don't know we might even see
something on the 7th when they have
their game place they're doing what May
7th yep what's that Thursday no Friday I
see new gameplay on the series 6 May 7th
well that makes sense because Sony
recently did a release a quote-unquote
whatever they were showcasing and it was
all for like investors and stuff like
that like make a consumer showcase this
is gonna be on the inside X Xbox yeah
yeah that makes more sense of what
PlayStation did that's what I want them
to do the PlayStation needs to do
something like that because the last
[ __ ] where they're like oh we're
gonna be doing a deep dive in the
PlayStation fire that was some mess ok
attention to that well do they really
should take the time to kind of rethink
their marketing both really I think to
do nothing what police station doesn't
know well what do you think that let me
let me rephrase this do you think that
PlayStation and Xbox are properly
promoting their consoles or do you think
it's just
offs as the hardcore gamerz knowing that
[ __ ] should be out soon why is it not
out yet we should be getting information
I think that a place I should does I
have to do the same marketing as Xbox I
think Xbox is doing better than they did
in 2013 but they still should be doing
more
I actually a hundred percent agree with
that PlayStation doesn't have to do
anything they won last console
generation and handed right they just
have to base exactly because that's
literally that's literally lazy oh we
think they might be not doing the best
but we don't know I think the I think
the major reasoning behind it is because
like they know they're significantly
further ahead than Xbox due to the last
console generation so they're gonna let
Xbox you know pick everything up first
present everything first and then
PlayStation is gonna try to rebound
around it right and that's why I think
we haven't seen the look the console
because I think they're still struggling
to figure out the heating and the
overheating and that's why we haven't
seen what it's finally gonna look like
because once they get that that's going
to determine how it's gonna look you're
talking about the police station yeah
cuz they're trying to beef it up more
because they're behind yeah so they're
trying to max that [ __ ] out so well with
maxing out comes overheating so well Mel
wheezy is actually saying something that
I actually agree with in Schad he said
that they actually didn't set Phil
Spencer stating that the pricing for
Xbox is gonna be cheaper and more
flexible and I think all of us agree
that we know that because they're gonna
be able to drop the price of the Xbox
and they're gonna be able to use game
pass to kind of pick up the pieces and
be able to fill in that money because
everybody knows game Pass is way better
than any other subscription that's out
right now like if you look at almost any
gaming subscription out right now for
any company you just ask yourself why
you should ask yourself how does it
compare to game pass because games
nothing nothing is it comes exactly so I
think that no matter what ends up
happening is I think that's how X bar
is gonna win this generation it's
they're gonna be able to pull in people
because of game paths and be able to
have a cheaper price yeah yeah they'll
pick up the pieces okay yeah 100%
they'll pick up pieces with campus they
need it the problem with I think Xbox
has everything every box checked off
right now they have variability in the
console where you can get different
tiers of power it's a it's a mini PC at
this point like yeah let's not sugarcoat
this
there are just many pcs at this video
but they have that you could these the
accessibility are on that there's
legitimate accessibility with what they
work through for the what's the gamepad
that they have they worked with their
AbleGamers yeah so they have they have
legitimate accessibility options for
everybody
they have backwards compatibility that's
unprecedented up until this point they
have been smart delivery they have they
have everything they just don't have the
games that's the one thing that they
don't have exclusives the exclusives
don't have the exclusive games that
people want to play they don't have to
want to play all the PlayStation play
single-player games like they don't have
those no not anymore at least yeah no I
mean Halo used to be a system seller
it's announced on exclusives soon at e3
maybe yeah thing yeah yeah it might be
possible it might be possible that you
have those companies that they ended up
buying up that has games sitting in in
the back that nobody knows about
or they might you know that that would
be something that's be very interesting
to know if they have triple-a titles
that nobody knows about that is
exclusive to Xbox it'll be it'll be very
interesting to see very interesting kind
of comment to put this back back to
where we what were what were originally
was talk about content creation
with you with kind of strike you you've
been streaming for a while doing your
counter-strike stuff yeah so like the
when we started the website we got for
some reason we got a following out of it
like we built a community some somehow
from three degenerates who just drink
and talk about video games we got a we
got a community out of it which is crazy
because we have like a bustle and
community right now but we ended up I
think it was a year after we had we
started the website we launched the
podcast and then shortly after or right
before that I tried streaming like
through my xbox which was a [ __ ] show
but I was playing a lot of yeah or no no
just to twitch actually at the time yeah
this was like before they Microsoft
tried doing the exclusivity stuff with
mixer and they like completely forgone
the twitch aspect of that Xbox but um
yeah I was I was trying to do like pub G
I was actually playing a little bit a
fortnight to write when fortnight came
out huh but outside of that like it was
just pub key and then I got after one
pax I got a PC like I started playing
games I was playing quake champions at
the time at PAX and my friends were
there showing me quake champions and one
of my friends is a former quake Pro who
won quake on in like 2009 or some [ __ ]
and he was like yeah I mean they all
were like you should just get a PC at
this point and I got my PC and like one
of the first things I did was set up a
streaming a way to stream more
consistently and that very that varied
in between like whatever I was playing
at the time it was a lot of pubsey at
the time more like I played for it night
every once in a while but more recently
I picked up counter-strike like a year
ago
almost I played source in 1.6 when I was
a kid growing up but I never really
understood it like it never no it was
just oh this is like a cool shooting
game I played all the mods and whatnot
would like the superpowers and and
everything but counter-strike like I
wanted to play a tactical
first-person shooter where I could feel
like I am I'm better than people yeah
like it's me being an [ __ ] like you
having a defined skill base exactly
that's established through like ranking
systems in red knob which is why I'm so
drawn to ranking systems and games
because I want to be as shitty as it
sounds I want to be better than people
at certain gamers in the world that are
you know they want to feel that they are
accomplished and they are strong and
then they are good at something and most
gamers
Darry want to be those types of
overachievers and I think ranking
systems are a great way for people to to
feel like they're progressing
feel like they're better than somebody
else like I could I could walk in
someplace and be like hey look at me I'm
a ranked 72 blah blah blah like there's
that soul oh yeah well that's that's
what I think a lot of those gamers
feeling they like yeah there's a there's
an innate competitive nature that I've
had since I was a kid like I played
sports my entire life growing up I just
I'm just ingrained with if I'm gonna
play if I'm gonna put my time into
something I want to be able to beat
people at it so which like I want to win
you didn't get a participation trophy
like at all the kids nowadays do no no
no I was before that time I looked I was
before that time as as the only parent
on the on the stream L had how do you
feel do you think participation trophies
yes or no or you want to have your kid
mailed you first second third yeah and I
like still because everyone does it so
like you have to work even harder to get
them to realize that like the world does
not work like that yeah you bust your
ass you earn that [ __ ] yeah I think but
I think you're making it harder for us
like they're making hard and for the
parents because like we have to keep
honing in the idea because they make it
seem like everything is rainbows and
them draw
so you know it's like they're gonna be
in for such a rude awakening I told my
niece all the time I'm like I'm not
letting you in
like I will sit there I'll play chess
with her right I'm not to the men who
I'm actually very good at playing chess
like I'll see my brothers come in and be
like oh you have to do I'm like Nana
Nana now she needs to learn how to play
chess yeah yeah I'm like I'll beat you
too
I was like but we need to like she needs
to learn how to play chess
I really beat her I regularly beat her
and like many things like no you have to
yeah like I don't know but I like I took
I like I said I literally grew up
playing video games every single season
there are not video games sports every
single season well video games too
actually but sports every single season
of my life growing up there I played
everything and I played consistently and
it was always I don't want to go onto a
field like I don't want to go into a
football football field or a lacrosse
field or a basketball court and I don't
want to just play to play I want to play
to win and so I can talk [ __ ] in the
middle of the game and then after the
game and then before the next game
that's how I that's my mentality of it I
want to beat you so you remember this
day for the rest of your life okay and
that's how it is that's how it is with
me and video games like I I I'm sure
Chris is still in here he's gonna he's
gonna freak out but like when I was
playing xbox
I was playing gears to almost
competitively I was ranked like in I was
wearing like 62 in the world at wingmen
with me and my friend mark the shark and
we were legitimately playing pros
consistently that's how good we were at
the game but we were - like we were too
immature at the time to understand oh
wait a second this is something we can
legitimately do like we could go to a
game stop and compete in a tournament
and we can leave with money
yeah like we were too immature at the
time we were just kids were in high
school like high school of middle school
we that we didn't understand it but we
had though we had legitimately had a
mechanical skill to play against adult
professional gamers that I actually this
one guy that comes into my stream every
so often he he was one of my first
followers believe it or not this guy
pika Shox and he's a great guy and he he
loves fighting games and it's not like
the regular fight that street fight or
moral comment stuff like that he does
all the anime stuff and I'm right there
with him I know I know I want I will I
wish we had more time to talk about that
with you but it was called he ended up
starting to play fighting games the
anime versions of them in his local area
and he started winning and winning and
bringing home money and like he was like
oh I don't know if I'm that good I don't
know how to I was like just keep playing
you'll get better it would get good and
you will start killing people and you
start winning is if you just keep going
and keep pushing keep pushing and he
ended up doing and he's doing it now and
he makes a little bit of money now here
and there and like he's graduating I
think his first semester of high college
and it's like he's like paying for his
college two fighting games yeah that's a
good that's like a really good time in
life to learn these things like like
high school or going into college cuz
like I figured it like it all clicked
for me like too late life yeah like I'm
27 years old I have a career at this
point like and I also have my my project
of a website to brands that I'm creating
yeah I can't it's so hot it would be so
hard for me and at this point in my life
like I'm can I actually put in like 40
hours of counter-strike every single
week no I can't but like if I could if
if this was 10 years ago I could like I
wouldn't go out I wouldn't play sports I
would dedicate my time to this and then
I could it would be something to pursue
but like even now at 27 I'm still at a
point where it's like I'll enter into a
tournament anyway I don't care because
if I lose I'll return them in a couple
of weeks ago we got stomped but like
we're gonna do yeah like I always said
like I wish I knew about
back when I was playing classic world
Warcraft I shouldn't say classic vanilla
world Warcraft because I was atop my
game I was good I could have had a
following I mean I was on a 24/7 I could
have been good but like it's now that I
know what I'm doing and what's going on
it's a lot harder yeah a lot harder
um yeah I'm Ju taking notes take some
notes right now yeah I know from seventh
grade
learn from us take some notes I started
off where you did off the Xbox one the
streaming and the quality is horrible so
uh so L do you have any questions for
Bob no I think I'll wait until they're
all together
yeah I need to get all that together
yeah she's been interesting for sure to
like a be three separate and another
yeah quick or did he like buy it Bowl so
once yeah so right when I bought my PC I
just it was like eight months after I've
moved home from graduate school so like
I was already in my career like making
the money I make today and it was I got
my taxes back and I said you know what
I'm gonna take all the tax returns call
my money I got back in taxes and I'm
just gonna dump it into a PC setup so
that's what I ended up doing I ended up
like blowing all of that on a good on a
like mid tier PC setup but then ever
since then it's been like how do I
upgrade do I get a better camera do I
get like a where do i yet do I upgrade
my webcam what do i do mic wise like
this is the third Mike I've had and I'm
probably gonna upgrade this at some
point - it's just like peripheral stuff
like figuring out Stream labs more every
single day yep stuff like that
it's good you there always has to be a
good like baseline starting point a lot
of people now like I don't I don't to
say your generation but the generation
below you there's a lot of people like
kids now
that are coming forward and saying this
is what my career needs to be I want to
be a streamer I want to be a content
creator I'm gonna do everything up front
I'm gonna put all this money into this
up front yeah but like they don't
understand gone through everything first
you have an experienced life yet they
also all of that now of being a content
creator I feel like is 90% marketing oh
yeah and the people now that are growing
up into it they have this weird
double-edged sword of they have all
family and friends from high school and
college and things like that that we'll
be able to produce a small you know a
group starting group but at the same
time they'll never grow because they
don't understand marketing whereas
adults will you just need to you
literally need to be an approachable
entity that's it if you are not a be
like I come off as abrasive the way I
talk to people no but like it it's from
a place of love you know
like what I'm playing video games like
I'm I'm gonna use an example of a buddy
of ours who's on our stream team Brad
loved the kid you know he's been one of
our day one since we launched the
website and our brand will play video
games together and I'll try to teach him
things but because of the way I say it
everybody's like dude stop being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what stop stop
talking to him like that I'm like no no
no hold on I'm just trying to teach
people right now but you also have to be
approachable like we're like you met us
you medicine person you met us first
hand we're not unapproachable people we
pride ourselves on being some of the
most approachable people in the industry
like you you can see people at huge
corporations walking around PACs and
it's almost like they walk around within
a factor of intimidation around them
like hey this is where we are in the
industry right now excuse us while we
walk through these crowds like dude
nobody wants to be involved with people
like that people want to be able to sit
down and have a conversation with people
that's why we we literally launched our
brand as
we're the people you sit down at a bar
with and you have a drink and you talk
about video games we don't there's no
there's no gatekeeping that we want we
want everybody to enjoy the content that
we create we want everybody to enjoy us
for who we are even though people love
to [ __ ] on me
I'm fine with that because I give people
[ __ ] right back that's just how it's how
I grew that's how all three of us grew
up actually that's how we know that's
how we know we appreciate one another is
if we could sit here and make fun of
each other that's I feel like that's the
that's the pinnacle of friendship yeah
well you all can just sit around and
bust each other's chops and you know
you're fine with it
like when when we were going up to pax
it was me King and cog and it's like a
3d change train ride up and throughout
the whole time we were just giving each
other crap the whole time and you know
what it was great no complaints it was
it was so much fun and you know when we
finally got everybody together like last
year when J was there and everything if
you feel like this group that does
cohesion that's just it's great and
that's that's that's awesome that you
know you have that with those guys -
good night gang thanks for stopping by
and I think this was something Bob oh
thanks for uh like hearing that guy yeah
I tried I tried to ban him also it was
some guy and just shot preaching was it
someone was it someone from my community
talking [ __ ] about me cuz I wouldn't be
surprised no I don't know what it was
like legit preaching it was like he was
reading from the book of X so anyway so
uh okay well we we are running a little
little bit long but I apologize for that
no no it's perfectly fine it's perfectly
fine I just I wanted to you know get a
little little understanding of you good
sir before we have everybody come on
next week about you know about you know
the week of your gaming site and
everything that's going on with you guys
specifically is you know as your
cohesion and all that other fun stuff so
I can't wait to like dive into that next
week
so as we as we you know we roll off on
the show Bob why don't you go ahead and
tell us where we can find you tell us
your socials and all that fun stuff yeah
so I am dr. Bob of Wicca gaming it's
wicked good gaming comm for all of our
written content you could check out the
YouTube content that I put up I do a lot
of our Chris does a lot of the podcast
vods up on YouTube but I'm also getting
like counter-strike content up Jim
content up on the YouTube it's
youtube.com backslash wicked gaming you
can listen to our podcast not another
gaming podcast on all podcast platforms
that's not another gaming podcast
brought to you by wicking a gaming my
personal snacking can you name them or
Portus or do I have to do it for you I
mean you could do it for me if you
wanted no it's on Twitch yeah TV
backslash wicked gaming yeah my personal
Twitter which I'm not super active on
but like I check it from time to time is
at wgg Bert you could check out all of
our socials at wicked gaming except for
Twitter it's ad wicked good games and
yeah I think that's it I would like to
say that I thought your name was
actually Bert for like the first two
days if my name has gone through
iterations over the past ten years with
all of my friends and it like it's my
friends outside of the gaming scene just
call me Rob yeah when we started all of
this I I did it give myself than the
like nomenclature dr. Bob somebody else
did because my friends would refer to me
as a doctor I'm not a doctor I'm a
physicist there's a difference but they
would call me a doctor because I'm the
only person that's gone that deep into
the medical field so I just I used that
as dr. Bob because ba it's you know dr.
Bob sounds better than dr. Rob nobody
wants nobody wants to go talk to dr. Rob
okay yeah and then it's a minute just it
took on a life of itself people just
started call me Bert Bobby you know
Bobby I don't Kali Reza
call me whatever you guys want give a
[ __ ] anymore
so thank you very much is there anything
anything else you needed to say uh no I
like I'm gonna listen to the podcasts
I'm gonna listen to the other at the
past few weeks that you guys had the
other guys on and it's like like I said
earlier first and foremost wicked gaming
was created to be a group of people that
you can approach and talk to about
videogames and that's how we've always
that was our that was our entryway into
the fridge into like our franchising and
stuff like it's our brands you know we
want to be approachable and you know
first end like you sat down with our the
podcast recording that we did at PAX you
know you know the type of people that we
are you know gotcha
well thank and thank you very much for
hanging out tonight with us really
people thank you for having me no
problem you're welcome
MJ won't you give us your socials um you
can find my twitch at MJ's a boss can be
streaming some warzone after this we can
find me on Twitter and Instagram at a
TMJ but for like personal life and stuff
like that snapchat is a beat 101 and
then also you can check me out on the
Lord's a gaming dotnet for the best
games with gold articles and and best
articles on a Lords gaming gotten head
out of everybody and as dizzy himself
he's out there in the chat what and yeah
now he was last time oh man yeah now
Zoey's in the bushes trying to watch me
well thank you thank you sir thank you I
appreciate you coming down so anytime
and you know I'm happy that you're
finally done with class so yeah yes l
how about you yeah I gotta say dizzy I'm
making that tomato soup he's in our
discord as well for growing the gaming
and he's always posting food he's
cooking so yeah I got tomato soup recipe
for you because I'm making his fabulous
um so we're gonna do that this week and
then you can catch me on Twitter
l-boogie Oh 208 on mixer elbow vo 208
Tuesday through Friday 7 p.m. to 10 p.m.
and then on Saturdays at the girl with
my gaming podcast that's 9 a.m. Pacific
12 p.m. Eastern sounds great if the
melatonin gummies is kind of a guide
your sleep cycle changed oh by the way I
put a note to make sure that you said
groan when we gave me way thank you very
much for coming in thanks for stopping
by
and joining us today and everybody knows
me it is now though SNA and so close so
close dude take it out sometimes I have
to read it off the cup or it's there
right there in the corner you check me
on Twitter discord Instagram twitch I am
on Twitch Monday to Friday evenings
starting at 7 o'clock and then going
until whenever I can deal with it the
Internet is finally hopefully going to
be fixed if you were here the beginning
you heard the fun and enjoyment so that
will be happening very very soon as I
said before next week we are going to
have the whole week of you gaming crew
here so make sure you guys are here it's
going to be funny
make sure you bring a beverage because I
am bringing a beverage about you - ok -
to welcome the rest of the crew here not
gonna go to off the off the over the
edge because I'm gonna have to work on
Tuesday but I'm doing for you guys and
much appreciated and as I said before
anyone if you have any questions please
email us at roundtable stream team at
gmail.com so we can ask questions - you
know the guess we are having on the show
please make sure you are following us on
Twitter on a table stream that way you
can end up seeing who's gonna be on the
show what's going on what's happening
things like that
we don't post on there that often but at
least you guys have an update of what is
happening with us yes and make sure you
guys are checking out the iron alerts
podcast Sundays at 1:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time and you know check out
lords of gaming that net for gaming news
almost podcast is actually in the
process of multi-platform streaming to
Twitter mixer YouTube possibly even
Facebook in the future
sort of something for you guys to know
if you guys are thinking of checking us
out on different platforms we want you
on YouTube because you know that's where
all the fun happens but we're gonna be
there so you guys all know and remember
everyone chew dream big and keep gaming
thank you very much and we will see
everyone next week thank you again bye
everybody
have a good one